VALLIAPPA LAKSHMANAN:
Let's talk about how
to accelerate data
powered innovation
within your enterprise.
We will look at some
of the key challenges
that enterprises face,
and a five step journey
that we have seen lots
of successful businesses
take to get to data
powered innovation.
We'll look at what enterprises
encounter along the way
and discuss how a Google
Cloud can help with examples.
Hello.
I'm Val Lakshmanan.
I lead Analytics and AI
Solutions at Google Cloud.
What are some of
the key challenges
that enterprises
face, especially when
it comes to data?
Well firstly, and probably
the most important,
is the size of data.
The amount of data
in most enterprises
is growing dramatically,
20% to 30% year on year,
such that, when you look
back after about five years,
you're looking at about a 5X
increase in the amount of data.
And it's not just
the size of the data.
By 2025, a quarter of
that data that you have
is going to be
real-time in nature.
And as you know,
real-time data is harder
to manage and maintain
than historical data.
In addition, much of the data
tends to be unstructured.
And today, less than
1% of unstructured data
is analyzed or even used.
And so these are some of
the key challenges when
it comes to data and
technology that's
used to work with the data.
And then put in
place the environment
that you're in today, and
you have unprecedented market
shifts.
And so you need to be
able to analyze the data,
process the data, increase
the velocity and scale,
if you want to power
data powered innovation
through your data.
And so, lots of
enterprises are driving
their data driven
business transformations
using Google Cloud.
So whether it's businesses
in retail or gaming
or financial services,
and all over the world,
whether it's in the Americas
or India or Japan and APAC,
we have experience
helping leaders
in all of these companies
bring about data-driven change.
And this consists of
a five step process.
And the first step is
to stop the bleeding.
You need to reduce the
cost of managing data,
especially as the data
sizes grow dramatically.
And one of the ways
that you do that
is by migrating the
data lake and data
warehouse to the Cloud.
Once you have your
data centralized,
the next bit is to break down
silos within the organization,
build a data culture to
democratize analytics.
And once you have everyone
within your organization
able to access the
data, process it,
the third stage
of the journey is
to be able to make decisions in
context faster and real time.
And I'll talk about what
I mean by in context.
But once you're in this
place where you're basically
doing descriptive analytics
as well as possible,
it is then a time to move on
to predictive and prescriptive
analytics.
And at that point, a
first step in the journey
is to look at end-to-end
packaged AI solutions
to leapfrog so that you're
not building everything
from scratch.
You're able to take
advantage of what's already
available in the marketplace.
And finally, to
be able to empower
data powered innovation
that is truly
differentiated by building
and operationalizing AI.
So let's walk through
each of these steps
and talk about what
enterprises encounter
along the way and some of the
things that we have to do.
The first step, as I said, is
to find the budget to carry out
data powered innovation.
And in order to
do that, you have
to lower the cost
of ownership, you
have to simplify operations.
And so that is the first stage
on the journey to carrying out
data innovation.
The problem is that your
traditional enterprise data
warehouse implementations, they
hinder business transformation.
First of all, they
can't scale fast enough
to keep up with this 5X growth
in data that we talked about.
And secondly, as 25% of the
data becomes streamed in nature,
it becomes really important
that all of your queries
are on fresh data.
And you need your
data to be fresh.
And that is a problem with a
lot of enterprise data warehouse
implementations.
Thirdly, when we talk
about breaking down
silos and building
a data culture,
it is extremely
important to make sure
that you do that
in a secure way.
And oftentimes, the way
that security is done
is it provides data
access restrictions that
inhibit collaboration
between different parts
of your enterprise.
And of course, the cost of
maintaining-- and by cost,
we don't just mean the
software costs or license
costs, but also the cost
of operationalizing it.
So you're basically
spending a lot of time
tuning the data warehouse rather
than getting insights from it.
And finally, we want to make
ourselves ready to carry out
machine learning and AI.
And that is also something
that traditional [INAUDIBLE]
implementations kind of hinder.
So that's the reason why
a lot of industry leaders
rely on Google
Cloud when it comes
to modernizing their data.
Whether it's Home
Depot who wanted
to accelerate their
time to value;
or Zulily, who needed to be able
to get instant insights for all
of their offers that
they create dynamically;
or Hearst Newspapers
wanted to use
advanced predictive
and analytics AI;
or AccuWeather, which is
looking at sharing data
not just within
their organization,
but with all of their partner
organizations, and to share
and have those kinds
of insights with ease.
And doing all of this in
a secure way, which like,
you know, you want to be
able to protect your data,
operate it with
trust, as HSBC does.
The technological
capabilities of Google Cloud,
the fact that our data
warehouse is serverless,
it's self tuning, that we offer
you high performance streaming
ingestion, that every SQL
query is automatically
streaming in nature, that you
can operationalize machine
learning without ever
moving your data out
of the data warehouse.
This is what allows you
to modernize your data
architecture.
And of course, all of this
is set up from the premise
that you need to find budget to
carry out your data innovation.
And that budget,
you're going to get.
Because by migrating
to the Cloud,
we can lower your
total cost of ownership
massively, so oftentimes, more
than a 50% reduction in cost.
But it's not just about
the data warehouse.
Because data platforms and
data rules are converging,
and they need to interoperate.
So when we talk about
a data warehouse,
a data warehouse today functions
often as a data lake also.
So, where we
traditionally used to have
extract, transform,
and load, these days,
you just extract and load
directly into a data warehouse.
And from there, you
transform as necessary.
And if you have Hadoop
workloads in your data lake,
you want those Hadoop workloads
to be able to read data
from your data warehouse.
And vise versa.
You might have queries
in your data warehouse
doing a Federated query
on your data link.
So, your data lake and
your data warehouse
need to be interoperable and
form the common data platform.
And this is true not
just to the technology.
It is also true from the
perspective of the people who
are going to be using the data.
So whether it is data analysts
using business intelligence
tools, or data scientists
using a data science platform,
or machine learning scientists
and data scientists using
TensorFlow and machine
learning, they all
need to be able to access data
whether it is in the data lake
or whether it's in
the data warehouse.
That interoperability
and this ability
to build a data platform
that combines both the data
warehouse and the data lake
are extremely important.
And that is the way they've been
designed Google Cloud's data
platform.
So, our idea is
that you need to be
able to derive a return on
investment from your data lake
so that it's a business asset,
and not just an IT cost.
So all of the things that
I've talked about in terms
of modernizing your
data warehouse,
they apply to a
data lake as well.
You want to get large
scale performance.
You want to do this
at a lower cost.
You want to be able to reduce
your operational complexity.
You definitely want to
make sure that you're
protecting your data,
that it's secure,
that you're breaking down data
silos between different parts
of your organization,
and they're
using AI to extract value from
all of your unstructured data.
So whether it's Pandora or
the Broad Institute or Metro,
all of these people
are building data lakes
for their unstructured data,
for their semi structured data,
and for their Hadoop
workloads on Google Cloud
such that it is
a business asset.
And for example,
dunnhumby had a blog
where they talked
about how they were
able to move from their
traditional monolithic Hadoop
cluster to ephemeral
clusters-- by ephemeral,
we mean a cluster
that is job specific--
and get a cost
savings of over 75%.
So again, the idea of
moving your data lake
into data warehouse,
the reason that it's
the first stage
in your journey is
that it opens up
the budget to do
all of the rest of the
innovation that you want to do.
And in order to
help you do that,
we have a lower risk offer
to migrate and modernize
your enterprise data
warehouses and your data lakes.
So if it's a data
warehouse, we have
ways to virtualize and translate
your queries automatically
and optimize and
reduce your cost.
If it's a data
lake, we have ways
to lift and shift, and then
move towards ephemeral clusters,
and then moving into a
completely serverless system.
Once you have moved your data
warehouse and your data lake
to the Cloud, the
next step is to look
at how to democratize
data access
and build a data culture
within your organization.
To talk about the
kind of benefits
that you get, take,
for example, HSBC
where they had to
calculate the liquidity
position of a country.
It used to take
them 10 hours to do.
But they were able to do
it in less than 30 minutes.
Then they were able to do
financial crime analytics
using BigQuery 10 times faster.
But the reason they
were able to do all this
was because they were able to
move their workloads to GCP
such that all of their
teams around the world
had access to capabilities
to help them innovate.
So we see the result
of the innovation.
But the reason that
that is possible
is because of this
democratization,
and of the breaking
down of data sites.
And if you're a
company that need
to move your data
to the Cloud, you
want to make sure that you're
moving it in such a way
and breaking down your data
silos in such a way that you
have strong security
and governance controls.
Right?
Especially when we
talk about, well, we
want to basically
provide access to data
from any team who can access
it who's allowed to access it.
You want to make sure
that all of your data
is encrypted in
transit, in rest.
There's not a bucket out there
that's somehow left open,
that you're able to bring
in your own encryption keys,
that you're able to use
Cloud DLP for classifying
and redacting sensitive data.
You're able to discover
data, that all of your data
that you're putting
onto the Cloud
is subject to third party
audits, and certifications.
If you need to be HIPPA
compliant, that you
can be HIPPA compliant.
And finally, that if
someone accesses the data,
there is access transparency
so that you can go look
at the audit logs
and you know who
has accessed it, when
they accessed it,
and why they accessed it.
So when you're
moving data and you
want to make sure
that your data is
available to a broad set
of your organization, one
of the key problems is, how
do we know what data I have?
And that's where Data
Catalog comes in.
We have a simplified data
discovery mechanism such
that you can go ahead and
find what data sets you have.
And Data Catalog has built-in
governance, that you can,
for example, say, you
can tag pieces of data--
not necessarily entire cables,
not necessarily entire data
sets.
But just columns, and say, these
columns are sensitive data.
And you can govern
sensitive data
across the organization in
a simple, straightforward,
consistent way.
But, one of the things
that happens is,
as you build your data
warehouse on the Cloud,
you start to
centralize your data.
You bring your data from SAP,
from Teradata, from Oracle,
from YouTube, from Google Ads.
And you centralize them
in the data warehouse.
The data warehouse on Google
Cloud is called BigQuery.
Once it's centralized there,
what many organizations find
is that they start to
see analytic silos.
So rather than carry out the
analysis in the data warehouse
itself, you see people
taking extracts of the data,
throwing it into spreadsheets,
throwing it into dashboards.
And all of these things start
to become slightly out of date.
So the next step
is to look at, how
can we do analytics
in a modern way?
And the way to do that is to
apply governance and control
to your KPIs.
And so, we're looking
at modern [INAUDIBLE]
and analytics such
that you can have
dashboards with
titles that are shared
across your organization.
Reports and
self-service, definitely.
But all of their self-service
reports and exploration
take advantage of
centrally built KPIs.
And this allows you
to take insights
and embed them into websites
and existing applications.
And also build data-driven
workflows and custom
applications with it.
So, it's one thing to
centralize your data.
But you also need
to look at, how
do I centralize the
analytics on the data?
How do I make sure that
those analytics themselves
are reusable instead
of everybody writing
their own Excel formulas, have
everybody writing their own SQL
queries.
And this is, again, something
that a lot of our customers
have found great benefit and
Credit Karma, for example,
says, there used to be a lot
of excel spreadsheets floating
around.
And now it's all in Looker
and under common governance.
Or Auto Trader talking
about democratization
of how they were, in a
matter of weeks, able
to go from nothing
to something that
was usable by all of
their sales squads.
So the first step is to
move your data to the Cloud.
Second step is to open up
access and build a data culture.
And the third step,
now, now everyone
has access to the
data, the third step
is to be able to make
decisions in context faster
and with real-time AI.
So one of the key things
when we talk about context
is that location is
incredibly important.
When we look at tabular
data from most enterprises,
we see that about
15% of tables tend
to have location
information in there--
store locations, customer
information, et cetera.
And you would need to be able to
do an accurate spatial analysis
within your data warehouse.
You don't want have a
separate geospatial database.
And that's one of the key
things that you can do
is that we can analyze GIS
data with familiar SQL, part
of your dashboards, and be able
to incorporate your location
information because location is
incredibly important context.
The second big piece
of context is time.
So, real-time data is
very, very, very valuable.
So there is a big
difference between being
able to act on a loan
three days later,
or being able to make
a decision on a loan
within a matter of minutes,
or within a matter of seconds.
Real-time is real value.
And whether it's in e-commerce,
or in gaming or manufacturing,
or in retail, you want to
be able to make decisions
as quickly as possible.
And in order to
do that, again, we
start with the data warehouse.
But the key thing to realize
is that in the data warehouse
on Google Cloud, every SQL
query is automatically streamed.
So all of the
investments that you
have done to get to the
point of democratizing access
and building dashboards and
building common analytics, all
of these actually work
in real-time as well.
What we need to
do is to make sure
that you're ingesting,
transforming,
and enriching the
data, and streaming it
into the data warehouse.
And that's something that we
do naturally in Google Cloud
because both Pub/Sub and
Dataflow, just like BigQuery,
are all serverless.
They are very easy to
operate, very low cost.
And you can spend
all of your time
getting insights from the data
rather than on operationalizing
and on the IT infrastructure
of building a messaging system
or building a data system.
And once you have your
data in the data warehouse,
you can do machine learning
directly in the data warehouse.
You don't have to move your
data out of your data warehouse.
And this allows you to
carry out machine learning
as part of your streaming
analytics by your clients,
for things like [INAUDIBLE]
action for example.
And this is an
incredible benefit.
Because normally, when you
talk about machine learning,
you're talking
about a data science
team that has to replicate
all of this data.
And whenever you replicate data,
you run into security issue,
right?
You have two copies of
your data floating around.
So BigQuery machine
learning, by allowing
you to do machine learning
directing your data
warehouse enhances
your security posture,
enhances your
access transparency.
And this is exactly what
A&B Tasty, for example,
was able to do.
They have 25 user
sessions per day.
They need to analyze
50 billion events.
And they wanted to
make better decisions
and obtain increased revenue.
And in order to
do that, they were
able to basically personalize
access to large volumes of data
within their company
to basically carry out
machine learning operations.
So at this point,
then, in the journey,
you have the ability
to have a data culture,
to be able to make
decisions in context--
spatial context,
temporal context.
And then, the next
step is to say, OK,
how can we now do more
prescriptive analytics?
And at that point,
you want to say,
you look around the marketplace.
It's not necessarily that you
have to build every piece of AI
that you need.
What can you buy?
Because when you buy,
you can leapfrog.
And at Google Cloud, we have
lots of readily embeddable AI
mod.
So for example, if you
want to process video,
and you want to do video
classification or action
recognition or
object tracking, you
don't need to go build
this from scratch.
We have an API that you can use.
And you can use it directly
and in your applications.
For example, if you want
to do a translation,
you don't need to go build
your own translation module.
Bloomberg, for example, every
time a news article comes in,
they need to send a global
update in 40 languages
to over 170 countries.
And they do that through
Google Translate.
And so the idea here
is that Bloomberg
is quite capable of building
their own translation model.
But they didn't.
Instead, what they did
was that they bought it.
And similarly,
right, if you want
to improve the performance
of your contact center,
there are three things that
you want to be able to do.
You want to be able to
look at standard queries
and automate them
as much as possible.
And if a query is handled
by a call center agent,
you want to make sure that
that query gets handled
the first time correctly.
You want to improve the customer
service, your office support
organization, by
providing the call center
agent all of the
information that they
need as soon as they need it.
And finally, you also
want to use the support
calls that are coming
in to understand
your business better.
And this is, again,
something that you
can build from scratch.
But why do that when
you can leapfrog ahead
with the contact center AI
solution from Google Cloud.
And that's what Ticketmaster
does, for example.
Or that's what Marks
and Spencer does.
Where they're basically taking
advantage of our contact center
AI solution to improve
their customer service.
Similarly, if you have forms and
you want to extract information
from forms, you want
to do form parsing,
you could build it from scratch.
Or you can use our
document AI intuition
and leapfrog ahead and allow
us to basically carry out
all of the hard work of doing
natural language processing
and building AI, et cetera.
Then, for example, if you
wanted to claims processing,
here's an insurance company that
was able to use our document
AI to get an incredible
reduction in the claims
processing and settlement
time by, again, leapfrogging.
So the key thing with
AI is to think about
what kinds of things
do I need to build
and what kinds of
things can I buy?
And when it comes
to buying AI models,
you want to buy AI models
that are high quality, that
have been battle tested.
And that's something that you
can get out of our platform.
The fifth step,
then, at this point,
you have prescriptive analytics.
But the prescriptive
analytics that you have
is primarily things that
you are able to buy.
The last step of the journey to
doing data powered innovation
is to empower your data
and machine learning teams,
and give them the tools
for them to be successful.
So, let's step back a
bit and think about,
I talked about
leapfrogging with AI.
And now I'm talking
about custom AI.
And the idea is that
in your organization,
you're going to have a
portfolio of business use cases.
Not everything needs to
be built from scratch.
And not everything
can be bought.
So, you need to look
at your use cases
and make a determination
of those use cases
on three criteria.
How fast do you want it?
How much effort do
you want to put in?
And how much differentiation
does this business
use case offer?
And based on that,
then you choose
whether you want to use a
fully prepackaged AI model.
Or do you want to take a
bunch of building blocks
and combine them
in a bespoke way?
Or do you want to
build custom AI that
is fully, fully differentiated?
And regardless of which
of these you want to do,
we have a platform that
allows you to do it,
that gives you the
ability to do it.
And we can partner
with you to help you
on this journey of whether it's
using the AI out of the box,
or building up on top
of our building blocks,
like auto ML and BigQuery,
and the Vision API, et cetera,
or whether you want
to do custom AI.
But the idea here is that you
will have lots of applications
that are collecting and
storing data into the data lake
and data warehouse.
That is the first part
of your journey to doing
data powered innovation.
And having done that,
then you basically
arm your data science teams to
be able to build and use AI,
and build and use AI
regardless of whether it
is AI out of the box or
building blocks or custom AI.
Being able to take it,
experiment with it,
generate insights from it.
But once you start to see that
this data science team is being
successful in the
developments phase,
you need to have the ability to
promote it and operationalize
the machine learning.
And that's where
we call MLOps to be
able to do this routinely, to
be able to monitor and retrain
the model when the
models start going out
of sync because of changes in
the environment of the data.
And, for example, eBay, for
example, uses custom AI.
Third part of my model
where they wanted
to do visual product search.
And at that point,
the training and image
classifier on 55
million product images
to get a 10% increase in
image recognition accuracy.
And 10% is an incredible
increase in accuracy.
But able to do that
10 times faster
because of the amazing
hardware called TPUs
that are available on Cloud.
Again, Google Cloud, incredibly
differentiated in terms
of both our data platform and
in terms of our AI platform.
So, when you are
taking your journey
to enable data
powered innovation
within your organization,
we can help you derive value
at every step of the
journey, whether it's
to reduce TCO in the
first stage, whether it's
to democratize analytics
in the second stage,
whether it's to be able
to make higher value
decisions in the third
stage, whether it's being
able to leapfrog
your competition
in the fourth stage, or
being able to really create
differentiated transformative
AI in the fifth stage,
we're happy to work with you
at every step of the journey.
Thank you.